what's up Jess Greg here it's John here
putting this break thank you good work
thank you alien covenants prologue the
crossing oh boy the cross I could use
more alien covenant footage right before
it comes out why not I could use more
dubious subtitles this is an even
stronger trailer it sounds like a scene
it does it doesn't sound like a scene
okay I've heard this is this the
prologue in the MOOC this is going to
explain some [ __ ] if I just share is
actually in the movie that's what I was
led to believe
you know what what's not even about us
given that in haste 2093 to prometheus
expedition when looking for humanity's
creators mission ended in disaster
discovery like an alien pathogen the
survivors continue their search that's
it Austin we made contact with the
engineers the Prometheus was destroyed
all hands were lost but I escaped
Elizabeth in one of their ships and we
were passed I was badly injured on our
mission she put me back together really
I never experienced such compassion how
she certainly not for mr. Wayne
great play
after this
okay
we were able to activate their ship
except I'd fix the hole we're finally
going to meet our Creator really
impossible say what if it happened so
long as and at worst
hey tight as you want pubic Illinois
just booked the boat like afraid my
favorite character from my side to
pretend now and then I was alone again I
learned the fairways and awaited our
arrival huh crossover I get it now
wow that was great
like that is amazing visuals right there
Wow and lastly pre-press visual there's
the good job team
[Music]
all right I guess they heard everyone
wondering if it's connected at
perfidious and instead of letting us
find that out they're like let's just
release the whole thing that establishes
where they've been what they've been
doing with not reveal the question that
everyone has got people looking the
wanting to find that let it come from
mine the mystery of our lead into the
area by giving everyone exactly what
they want to see answers and everything
we thought David was just a talking head
nope she put him back together maybe
this is an attempt to get more people to
buy copies of Prometheus it ended up
seeing this year line open but David and
David and Elizabeth were the good care
yeah and maybe people are gonna want to
watch Prometheus and go maybe this one
gives answers now because that's one
hand gently this whole setup is about if
they have answers
I think 20th Century Fox was like we got
to make sure people don't think the
wasting their time so even though people
kind of want to watch this movie already
to tell you that answers there let's
just put it out there right now feel
like they had people once they showed
that alien like screeching at top of the
spacecraft and they were obvious they
like they said the Prometheus ship in
the trailer like for the real fans are
targeting here they knows that I mean I
guess the average non movie goer who
casually watches movies who I probably
am going to assume is not that invested
in to permit is not debating the Med
pond yeah it's probably seen the alien
covenant thing and not really truly
realizing the connection between
Prometheus and your covenant without
someone having to try to explain it to
them it does happen so maybe this is
also for those guys but I feel like
anyone who watches these exclusive clips
release online probably already this
stuff's I don't think they need to cut
because that now the movies really
you know for if you don't give answers
you are [ __ ] on this French Concession
so I will not give it I will not return
for another I'll be like I'm boycotting
this third one if you don't give us a
single goddamn answer about our creators
setting up with got some answers now I
really don't want to be cynical about
this the way they like advertising this
thing all along has just been so weird
even an even pre-production
advertisement has been so over here done
yeah because every time I talk to her
Lee Scott it's a different story and I
can't tell it that yeah do do just
really wants to make a lien or if it's I
think we've probably honestly I like I
care more about prometheus too than a
lien prequel at this point I did yeah
well I I don't know what I what I hope
for this movie is I know he can do a
really cool sci-fi horror like I know
that religion knows how to do that yeah
but is it good enough to be alien like
is it is it does it have something to
say or do enough that it merits bringing
out the alien [ __ ] you know well if you
look back at alien and aliens it was I
know Ridley Scott was involved with but
this is look at what he created with
alien none of that capitalizes on its
world and mythology so much like what
makes that movie such a great experience
what makes that movie such a great
experience that it's a wonderful sci-fi
horror film and now Elena ventured onto
this you know project of Prometheus he
was looking for now let's expand the
world in the mythology and try to hone
in on that and when he's shown with
alien covenant and trailer so far is
that he's got sci-fi horror down like
you're saying but all this other stuff
of expansion it didn't seem to pan out
too well for Prometheus and it seems
like the alien coven and trailers are
not even trying to really show it that
they're going to explore that so they
released this clip I'm trying to figure
out the process minor it is going off so
they released this clip showing no we're
still going to go with that the thing is
if alien covenant is just a good sci-fi
horror film okay I'll walk out and give
it a good thumbs up at the same time
though alien covenant is set up in a way
where I will be disappointed if you
don't do a good job on all these other
are trying to explore outside of sci-fi
for you're trying to explore real
science fiction [ __ ] now
yeah with a mythology world and the
creation of these aliens because before
were made we made his first daily movie
so specials we didn't know what the [ __ ]
the aliens work even though oh I got
that I was this like a deep expansive
philosophical dissertation about
something like this is gonna become like
a crazy FD Asterix French the thing is
he has to make that element work now
yeah yeah has to it has to actually be
smart because that's why I'm not exactly
like super psyched about it even though
I see the triggers like pretty [ __ ]
cool and I'm definitely intrigued I am
concerned about all that other [ __ ] that
he started inventing when he started
working on what was the alien pretty
cool then became Prometheus yeah I'm so
many nails that [ __ ] defconn's the movie
alien coming it has to be more than a
good sci-fi horror movie I'll still have
fun with it but it has to be if alien
just remain only just a good sci-fi
horror film that was it then cool that's
what alien 1 through 4 is this is good
sci-fi horror flicks yeah oh what
they're do it's gotta be special in some
way because like love them or hate them
even even the deeper sequels you can't
really accuse any of those movies yeah
not being distinct you know like not
going for what they're going for
absolutely each one's different I feel
like has to be special because it's like
what's happened to terminator is like
each one's kind of not delivered on
something and now with the Genesis is
like Genesis a lot of fun at its core I
didn't feel like it did terminator
terminator 2 justice I'm afraid that
that's going to happen to this because I
think the word that can happen is a baby
that is just a cool movie yeah bit cool
action movie at this point it can't be
that thing there was a time where all
the Alien movies need to be but after
Prometheus now you got a eat you can't
just go back to oh a cool another one of
alien you know and that's one of the
more interesting things to me about this
shifting over to the more positive side
because I do still get excited about a
lingas alien day-to-day I want stompers
so bad so I do want to give this a
chance and like I think that he can't do
it but it's the Martian happened and I
was like wow that's it yeah movie
holy [ __ ] really Scott well I have you
restored my face enough that like the
next thing you do I will go see I hope
he nails this and the thing that makes
me wonder about this for better and
worse is the direction that this clip
took at the end where they're like
landing on some kind of create like
puzzle thing and like yeah like because
that's the kind of [ __ ] the Covenant
trailers have not been exploring yet
well this is looking like way more
expensive in the scope like it seems
like it's really gonna broaden out its
universes so as much as we'd like back
on the back of the clip revealed so much
and that kind of would have been cool or
just to watch the movie yeah that
happens here's the power we saw it at
the same time and even though it's
something I always felt was negativity
towards it it is kind of relieving
because it's like okay that they're
they're going to continue this part for
sure because it looked like from the
trailer is that like it's going to focus
on this new ship and then they go there
and eventually they're going to have
like a cameo with David in a cameo and
knew we're upon that's what I thought
the movie was setting up to be light but
to show that this is if that means I was
an online clip or it's a prologue that's
in the official movie it's showing that
it that's definitely going to be an
element of they're going to continue to
explore and hopefully give some answers
to you know be cool as if the other crew
came in like halfway through the movie
so they're like you actually continue
the the David and yeah I mean Elizabeth
story for like a while yeah because then
like almost everything they've said
about this movie could be correct just
in less movies than five yeah yeah like
oh we're actually going to continue
prometheus for a while and then it
becomes alien whoa yeah which could be
at very least I just hope they give
David and and there was the time because
like if they just rush through it like
three minute montage yeah this is it
yeah I'm a new guy and I like that would
be kind of a fun yeah I hope they're I
hope they're really featured or us
crucial element in a film for sure what
some of these visuals reminded me of
other movies you know which is just
interesting to me like it seems like
it's at least he's borrowing from some
other pallets you know stashing maybe a
different
Hoan for this release guy I mean if
there's one thing in credit gown he's
definitely a multi John or director so I
could always see him like borrowing
other palettes as you say because there
was like there was at least one shot in
there were like I really did get pulled
in like when it's that like scope shot
about them docking on that thing that
was pretty amazing and just like the
city around out like wow this looks
distinct not what I would have expected
from this user yeah but maybe this could
become like a weird sci-fi horror Lord
of the Rings it's like these movies tell
work if every planet we visit is like
special for some really because if it's
Rivendell and Gondor in it and all that
[ __ ] yeah I don't think all that auto
planets just look like nature if they
mess well yeah and then there's no one
there yeah cuz there s or the planets of
this exploration have been to be going
yeah I don't want to be calling it I
don't think it would be good if it
became just a repeat of that Jerry oh
yeah if you just kept redoing predator
Preta predator as just the same cousin
just different people we just here drop
different people onto this planet and do
the same thing they could take this
chance to broaden out the kind of movie
this is going to be you know that's sure
that can be cool I don't know where they
got to but it looks intriguing and if
they can start giving some some nice
answers and some you know
well-thought-out story points with that
it could be really you know cool and
worth the time I just hope it's not a
lot of cool-looking [ __ ] but the snake
looking [ __ ] I predict this someone get
a 68 on Rotten Tomatoes ooh
68 percent pay you can subscribe to the
real rejects if I'm an optimist I will
say 77 because 77 the cool edgy numbers
oh you're a naughty movie reason to GRE
on Twitter and Instagram
social media manager of Blum house and
the real rejects and go check out our
recently launched patreon become a
member of the patreon reject community
the reject ons the rejected [ __ ] an item
attracting checks the reach and retract
or extract objects that sounds like if
you had a bat belt if Ryan
had a bat bell to retract objective